[Music]  I'm detective what's in it Elliot and  this is trooper Wagner we just want to  ask a few questions  we understand none of his demise the  family have gathered to celebrate your  father's 85th birthday  [Music]  how was it hello the party pre my dad's  death it was great ladies and gentlemen  I would like to request that you all  stay until the investigation is  completed  what can we ask why has something  changed no no it hasn't changed or no we  can't ask one of his family walls is  that what you're suggesting  [Music]  love twisting the knife into one another  up your ass oh very perfect we [ __ ]  how's that eat [ __ ] [ __ ] definitely eat  you know something spill it  I suspect foul play  I have eliminated no suspects  - twisted web we are not finished  untangling it not yet  what is this CSI KFC  [Applause]  [Music]  you